einen guten freitagmorgen wünsche ich
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen meine
damen und herren herzlich willkommen in
der bundespressekonferenz auch heute
werden wir wieder vielfältig übertragen
nur über phoenix können sie die
gebärdensprachdolmetscherin sehen für
die wir auch von phoenix unterstützt
werden herzlichen dank zwei sätze zu uns
die bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation in
der sich hauptstadt korrespondentinnen
hauptstadt korrespondentinnen
zusammengeschlossen haben die eben über
bundestag und bundespolitik berichten
wir vom vorstand gewährleisten dass wir
möglichst viele fragen gestellt werden
können
wir freuen uns natürlich dass unsere
gäste auch in pandemie zeiten unsere
gäste sind pandemie bedingt arbeiten wir
mit einem reduzierten zeitkontingent von
einer stunde und ich darf heute begrüßen
den bundesminister für gesundheit jens
spahn sowie professor lothar wieler
präsident des robert koch institutes und
professor klaus cichutek präsident des
paul ehrlich institutes es geht heute um
die korona lage im lockdown ersparen sie
haben das wort ja liebe frau welche
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
ziemlich genau vor einem jahr wurde das
erste mal dass kroner virus in
deutschland entdeckt wir erleben heute
ein jahr später harte wochen des
lockdown der start der impfkampagne war
schwierig es gab verzögerungen bei den
lieferungen aus der eu bestellung
teilweise überlastung bei der
terminvergabe das alles hat zur
enttäuschung geführt
gleichzeitig ist und bleibt es ein
großer erfolg dass wir ein jahr nach
beginn der pandemie drei wirksame und
sichere impfstoffe zur verfügung haben
wir haben jetzt die mittel des virus zu
besiegen nicht sofort aber im laufe des
jahres inzwischen sind bei uns in
deutschland knapp 3 millionen impfdosen
verabreicht worden
über 800.000
schon die zweite dosis erhalten das ist
ein prozent der bevölkerung und damit
übrigens innerhalb der europäischen
union für die zweitimpfung auch eine
hohe quote weil wir bewusst ja auch die
strategie haben in den
pflegeeinrichtungen dort wo die
besonders gefährdeten sind die
zweitimpfung auch frühstmöglich
innerhalb des vorgesehenen intervalls zu
machen
inzwischen haben 630.000 und damit fast
80 prozent der bewohnerinnen und
bewohnern in pflegeeinrichtungen
die erstimpfung bekommen fast die hälfte
von ihnen auch die zweite das heißt und
das ist ja auch unser ziel wir schützen
zuerst diejenigen die am stärksten durch
das coroner virus gefährdet sind und es
werden jeden tag mehr
das macht in dieser pandemie einen
echten unterschied
gleichzeitig sinken die infektionszahlen
noch nicht stark genug noch nicht weit
genug
aber sie sinken erstmals seit dem
vierten november also nach drei monaten
haben wir weniger als 200.000 aktiv
infizierte in deutschland erstmalig seit
dem 24
oktober sind wir wieder unter der 80er
instituts diese ermutigende entwicklung
haben wir uns als gesellschaft durch
konsequenz und auch durch viel verzicht
erarbeitet deshalb sollten wir das so
mühsam erreichte nun nicht leichtfertig
verspielen
das sind wir uns selbst schuldig wir
haben in einigen ländern auch in einigen
ländern der europäischen union gesehen
wie schnell das gehen kann nachdem man
ein niedriges niveau erreicht hatte dass
die zahlen wieder nach oben schnell
die ansteckenden virus mutationen haben
ihren weg auch nach deutschland gefunden
dazu wird in der professor wieder gleich
die details nennen die auch wichtig sind
vor den beratungen kommende woche wenn
wir diesen mutationen die möglichkeit
zur ausbreitung geben würden riskierten
wir einen erneuten anstieg der
infektionszahlen aber wir müssen auch
perspektiven aufzeigen
jetzt geht es darum mit augenmaß den
richtigen zeitpunkt den richtigen weg
mit der richtigen geschwindigkeit aus
dem still
stand zu finden dazu erarbeiten bund und
länder konzepte darüber werden wir
nächste woche mit den
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten sprechen viele
familien mit kinder sind am limit und
wir vergessen sie nicht wir wissen unter
welchen starken druck sie im moment
jeden tag stehe ich für mich ist klar
wenn und sobald wir öffnen dann zuerst
bei kitas und schulen in deutschland
steht dieses wochenende der dritte
impfstoff zur verfügung mit astra zenica
haben wir ein vakzin ein impfstoff der
einfach zu lagern ist und den wir nach
dem bekannten anlaufschwierigkeiten nun
in größerer menge bekommen werden weil
noch die datenlage fehlt um astra zenica
bei älteren anzuwenden ändern wir die
impfverordnung die prioritäten gruppen
bleiben mehr oder weniger gleich
allerdings bekommen jüngere die 18 bis
64 jährigen nun vorrangig in astrazeneca
im stoff die älteren jahrgänge vorrangig
den vom bayon tech moderner damit können
wir die älteren und die pflegekräfte
schneller impfen und schützen
das ermöglicht uns eine verdopplung der
impfung bereits jetzt im februar im
vergleich zu dem was nur mit beyond echo
moderner schon geplant war
und ja es gibt manches vorurteil und
herr professor cichutek wird sicherlich
auch darauf gleich noch ein gehen mir
ist eines wichtig wenn ein impfstoff
zugelassen ist wird er auch und die
ständige impfkommission hat alle drei
impfstoffe als gleichermaßen geeignet
für den individual schutz wie für die
anwendung in dieser pandemie für die
gruppen immunität bezeichnet dieses
vertrauen können wir in die
zulassungsbehörden und in die ständige
impfkommission haben wir haben mit allen
drei mit impfstoffen wirkungsvolle
werkzeuge um dieser pandemie zu begegnen
und wir hoffen und rechnen damit dass
bald noch weitere dazukommen
meine damen und herren dieses
jahrhundert pandemie bleibt für uns alle
eine zumutung und
sie bleibt einen charakter und stress
test für unsere gesellschaft
ich bin weiterhin davon überzeugt dass
wir diesen test bestehen heute rund ein
jahr nach dem ausbruch von corona in
deutschland möchte ich als
bundesminister für gesundheit
all denjenigen danken die seit einem
jahr ohne pause für uns an der front im
einsatz sind die pflegerinnen und
pfleger die ärztinnen und ärzte all
diejenigen den apotheken in den praxen
in den laboren in allen
gesundheitsämtern jeden tag rund um die
uhr an jedem wochenende zu unserem
schutz für unsere gesundheit arbeiten
auch ihnen allen sind wir es schuldig
dass wir jetzt noch ein wenig
durchhalten und ja auch ich bin diese
pandemie leid
auch ich will wie alle anderen so
schnell wie möglich zurück zur
normalität
zur freiheit zur gewohnten
unbefangenheit auch wenn uns der
lockdown jetzt im winter manchmal daran
zweifeln lässt
auch wenn noch weitere harte wochen vor
uns liegen wir sind auf dem weg raus aus
der anime und diesen weg gehen wir
entschlossen aber vorsichtig vielen dank
herr spahn guten tag meine damen und
herren die fallzahlen gehen in den
meisten regionen in deutschland weiter
zurück das sind sehr gute nachrichten
auf der anderen seite sehen wir dass die
intensivstationen immer noch stark
belastet sind und es gibt immer noch
viele ausbrüche in altenheimen und
leider auch noch sehr viele todesfälle
die zahlen und daten finden sie wie
immer auf dem dashboard des
robert-koch-instituts als auch den
situationsbericht den ich hier nochmal
zeigen den wir jeden tag publizieren
unter www.rki.de also die situation ist
noch lange nicht unter kontrolle was uns
im robert-koch-institut große sorgen
macht sind die besorgniserregenden noch
ansteckender und varianten des virus
aktuell sind es drei besorgniserregende
varianten die wir im blick
die variante b 11 7 13 51 und b 1 1 281
alle drei varianten wurden in
deutschland bereits nachgewiesen wir
haben jetzt einen ersten überblick wie
häufig die varianten zur zeit in unserem
land vorkommen
besonders die variante b 1 1 7 das ist
jene variante die erstmals in
großbritannien nachgewiesen wurde
im moment ist es die von den drei
besorgniserregenden varianten am
weitesten in deutschland verbreitete
diese variante ist ansteckender als die
bisherigen und es gibt auch erste
hinweise dass sie auch vermehrt zu
schweren verläufen führen kann
um einen überblick zu bekommen haben wir
verschiedene daten genutzt und
ausgewertet da ist zum einen das
ergebnis einer ad hoc erhebung in
laboren von letzter woche darin wurden
rund 31.000 positive saß koch zwei
proben mit einem speziellen pcr test auf
die varianten nachuntersucht
außerdem haben wir die genomsequenz
daten ausgewertet und zu dem auch die
meldedaten der gesundheitsämter w 11 7
ist bislang in 13 bundesländern
nachgewiesen worden
das ist der stand von anfang der woche
und diese variante b 17 macht ihn zur
zeit in deutschland einen anteil von
etwas weniger als 6 prozent aus wer 117
wurde in den letzten wochen auch immer
häufiger nachgewiesen was bedeutet dass
aus unserer sicht
erstens die drei varianten vor allem bei
117 sind in deutschland angekommen
zweitens sie dominieren das geschehen
noch nicht aber wir müssen damit rechnen
dass sich der anteil weiter erhöht
ähnlich wie es auch in anderen
europäischen ländern berichtet wurde in
den letzten wochen
der bericht zu den varianten den finden
sie jetzt auf den webseiten des robert
koch- institut unter www.rki.de
wir müssen also damit rechnen dass sich
vor allem bei 117 weiter vor
leitet und dass die pandemie bekämpfung
dadurch erschwert wird
diese variante ist ansteckender und saß
cause 2 ist also insgesamt gefährlicher
geworden
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir alle
maßnahmen weiter konsequent umsetzen um
ansteckungen zu verhindern
wir müssen die ausbreitung von saas koch
und auch der varianten zumindest
verlangsamen und wir müssen verhindern
dass neue varianten entstehen natürlich
behalten wir alle diese varianten im
blick meine damen und herren wie sie
auch wissen wird die datengewinnung über
genomsequenzierung in deutschland
derzeit massiv ausgebaut
nur um in ein stichwort zu geben im
ganzen jahr 2020 haben wir rund 1500
sequenzdaten in deutschland generiert
den gesetz stehen allein im januar
diesen jahres sind es rund 3500
genomsequenz daten und im
robert-koch-institut wird zudem die
sogenannte integrierte molekular
surveillance ausgebaut dank dieser
können wir zb genomsequenzen von laboren
in ganz deutschland zusammen mit
epidemiologischen daten aus den
gesundheitsämtern integriert analysieren
und bewerten und so können wir die
gefährlichkeit neue varianten
einschätzen und die virusvarianten auch
in deutschland besser überblicken und
die ad hoc labor erhebung von der ich
eben sprach die werden wir noch
wiederholen in der woche sechs acht und
zehn
ja meine dauern kann offensichtlich wird
es besser werden jede impfung ist ein
wichtiger schritt in die richtige
richtung aber meine damen und herren das
virus ist noch nicht müde im gegenteil
es hat gerade nochmal einen boost
bekommen und deshalb müssen wir
unbedingt dranbleiben kontakte
einschränken wo immer möglich
abstand halten hygieneregeln beachten
masken tragen lüften und bitte möglichst
auf jede reise verzichten die nicht
zwingend notwendig ist geben wir quitt
19 keine chance herzlichen herzliche
bitte meine damen und herren ich möchte
noch mal darauf aufmerksam machen wie
bereits von hermes
erwähnt dass wir das glück haben drei
regulär zu last und cupid 19 impfstoff
produkte bereits in der eu verfügbar zu
haben
wie sie wissen handelt es sich um
genetische impfstoff auf mr basis das
neueste mitglied dieser gruppe ist der
impfstoff von astrazeneca original bei
der oxford university erarbeitet und
konzipiert ein weg zur impfstoff bei
werkstoffen besteht bereits erfahrung
aus dem nivola impfstoffen und anderen
durch den einsatz dieser zugelassenen
wirksame impfstoffe haben wir jetzt
gemeinsam die chance die pandemie
wirksam zu begrenzen
und ich möchte herausstellen alle
impfstoff produkte die in der eu geprüft
wurden und von der kommission zugelassen
wurden haben ein günstiges
nutzen-risiko-verhältnis sie sind für
den schutz vor coop 19 zu empfehlen und
ich glaube ich brauche nicht wiederholen
das ja durchaus auch bei personen im
alter von unter 64 jahren das risiko
eines schweren cupid verlaufs mit
folgeschäden besteht mitunter super
eines tödlichen verlauf wie ist der
astra zeneca impfstoff unser jüngstes
impfstoff produkt geprüft worden
nun zum einen wurde sichergestellt dass
dieser impfstoff konsistent
qualitätsgesichert gestellt wird er hat
eine hohe qualität und zusätzlich
gewährleistet die staatlichen chargen
freigabe des paul-ehrlich-instituts dass
jede chance von impfdosen diesen hohen
qualitätsanforderungen genügt zweitens
dieser impfstoff wurde üblich wie bei
anderen impfstoffen auch geprüft an
tieren an ratten mäusen altweltaffen
hier wurde die sicherheitsfirma kohl ogi
untersucht um sicherzustellen dass es
keine schäden geben kann oder
physiologische abnormalitäten es wurde
sogar mit einem unter mit einer
untersuchungsmethode gary peters
toxicity nennen wiederholte im stoff in
größerer menge gegeben auch hier haben
sich
die eigenschaften des impfstoffs hat
sich heraus gestellt und ich möchte
darauf aufmerksam machen
es gibt ja durchaus auch sogenannte
nicht um eine primaten versuche an
altweltaffen die hier notwendig sind für
die sicherheit und hier hat man
festgestellt dass dieser impfung schäden
vermeiden kann weil er vermeidet oder
begrenzt die infektionen der unteren
atemwege wie lange und dann wie vielen
personen wurde dieser impfstoff geprüft
nun allein in der phase 3 prüfen würde
ein stoff von über 10.000 personen mit
zwei dosen verimpft die wirksamkeit für
alle altersgruppen bis etwa 64 jahre
wurde statistisch signifikant ermittelt
und beträgt 60 prozent macht der
klinischen prüfung aber auch die
wirksamkeit in ladestrom darüber hinaus
jetzt hoch sein wenn ja an die älteren
personen denken weil der grad der
immunreaktion vergleichbar hoch war wie
bei den jüngeren
und wenn man in betracht zieht dass die
grippe impfstoffe die wir jedes jahr
verenden eine wirksamkeit zwischen 16
und 80 prozent durchschnitt haben so ist
die wirksamkeit eines kurve dem stoff
von 60% ausgezeichnet und wird uns
helfen die panini zu bekämpfen
ich möchte zusammenfassen der
zugelassene astrazeneca cupid 19 links
stoff genau wie die beiden anderen hat
ein günstiges nutzen risiko profil
er ist nach den üblichen regeln geprüft
worden
er erfüllt die kriterien die wir selber
seines polnischen institut im ausschuss
für humanarzneimittel festgelegt haben
mit einer wirksamkeit deutlich über 50
prozent und eine sehr gute
sicherheitsprofil
er ist nach den ergebnissen der
klinischen prüfungen im vergleich zu den
impfstoffen möglicherweise auch etwas
verträglicher er wird übrigens das kann
ich ihnen zum letzten konferenzen mit
den kolleginnen kollegen in europa sagen
überall in europa empfohlen und auch die
ständige impfkommission hat hier klare
maßstäbe gesetzt genauso wie die vero
diesen impfstoff empfehlen wird
ich möchte eine weitere positive
nachricht geben system noch mehr
impfstoff produkte zuzulassen
darüber können wir uns unterhalten und
wenn diese zugelassen sind werden sie
genauso nützlich sein und ein günstiges
nutzen risiko profil besitzen dafür
stehen wir mit unserer jahrelangen
erfahrung und expertise bei der prüfung
der entsprechenden daten
meine damen und herren durch den einsatz
dieser impfstoff habe wirklich gemeinsam
die chance die pandemie wirksam zu
begrenzen
und ich glaube jeder einzelne von uns
sollte den schutz durch impfung in
anspruch nehmen sobald die impfung
angeboten wird auch so schnell wie
möglich und für sich selbst die eigene
familie aber auch das eigene umfeld und
nicht zuletzt unsere gesellschaft zum
wohle dieser gesellschaft die impfung
annehmen
wir haben hier sehr gute ihm stoffe zu
bieten wir haben uns für den regulären
weg der prüfung entschieden und das ist
glaube ich eine gute nachricht heute
danke schön
ich danke ihnen wir haben jetzt 40
minuten zeit für fragen das ist knapp
bei der langen liste an wortmeldungen
die ihn mir jetzt schon vorliegt ich
bitte darum eine frage zu stellen
gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage und sich
möglichst kurz und präzise zu fressen
haben es beginnt wenn sie sich
vorstellen
die spätere zweite chance nicht zu
schaden
die zeit nimmt um dieses auch im golf
aus meiner sicht ist das derzeit nicht
gesichert
und sie wissen das von der zulassung her
die daten die statistisch signifikante
wirksamkeit belegen einen zeitraum von
vier bis zwölf wochen betrachtet haben
die ständige impfkommission hat hier
weitere auswertungen noch zu grunde
gelegt um zu empfehlen dass er zwischen
neun und zwölf in zwei wochen geben
werden soll das ist das intervall
zwischen erster und zweiter und dieses
intervall hat schon den vorteil dass
tatsächlich gewisse zwischen der
auswertung tendenzen zeigen dass dieser
spätere zeitraum für die zweite impfung
den vorteil hat dass die wirksamkeit
noch etwas besser ist ich glaube das ist
die datenlage die wir jetzt haben auf
die sollten wir uns verlassen wenn es
neuere daten geben sollte mit hoher
effizienz aus dem alltagsgebrauch so
kann natürlich die empfehlung
entsprechend angepasst werden und auch
die zulassung
natürlich waren wir auch das möchte ich
noch einmal sagen ganz klar auf weitere
daten aus den laufenden klinischen
prüfung der phase 3 was die sicherheit
und wirksamkeit anbieter zu setzen
da halten wir würden dem großen das kann
ich noch nicht absehen derzeit ich kann
nur sagen im vorfeld der zulassung haben
wir allein gehofft auf spätere
interimsanalyse die uns vorgelegt werden
aber es ist manchmal nicht trivial auch
bei erfahrenen und firmen die
entsprechenden daten gut aufzubereiten
und nach stand der technik auszuwerten
das brauchen manchmal lange zeit dass
astrazeneca fragt auch anke schröder von
einer japanisches fernsehen die ema hat
den impfstoff für alle über 18
zugelassen aber betont dass es nicht
genügend daten für personen über 55 gibt
die stiko empfiehlt den impfstoff nur
für personen von 18 bis 65
woraus resultiert dieser unterschied von
zehn jahren bezieht man sich da auf
unterschiedliche daten das ganz einfach
zu erklären
wir haben von seiten der zulassung hier
einen sehr wurden evidenz maßstab
angelegt aber wir haben auch die
möglichkeit zu extrapolieren was die
stiko in anderer weise durch
modellierung und ähnliches tut
und hier war klar dass die harte
datenlage statistisch signifikant zeigt
dass nachgewiesen wurde in der laufenden
klinischen prüfung zum zeitpunkt der
auswertung und zum zeitpunkt als wir die
entscheidung für die zulassung treffen
mussten
dass wir sehr gute wahl wie dance daten
von 18 bis 55 jahren haben aber wir
können extrapolieren aufgrund der daten
der immunreaktionen auch bei älteren
dass der impfstoff auch gute wirksamkeit
haben wird darüber hinaus und deswegen
haben wir es von seiten der zulassung
dazu entschlossen keine altersbegrenzung
einzuziehen
aber ein hinweis zu geben dass die
datenlage bis 55 besser ist die ständige
impfkommission hatte noch eine 300
zwischenauswertung vorliegen
die gezeigt hat dass es durchaus sehr
gute tendenzen gibt zur wirksamkeit bis
zum alter von 64 jahren und hat sich
entsprechend entschlossen
sprechen kann herr kollege bitte
ich hatte um eine frage und
gegebenenfalls eine nachfrage gebeten
dankeschön
also zuerst einmal folgen wir der
empfehlung wie auch in allen anderen
bereichen der ständigen impfkommission
was im 18 bis 64 jahre angeht ich würde
- darauf hinweisen falls und wenn neuere
daten bessere daten auch für ältere
vorliegen und die von der ständigen
impfkommission ausgewertet werden kann
das eben dann auch schon in wenigen
wochen zu anderen entscheidungen führen
es wird ja immer aktuell ausgewertet
aber der umstand dass mehr impfstoff zu
einer verlangsamung der kampagne führt
dem kann ich jetzt noch nicht ganz
logisch folgen wir haben allein durch
den astra zenica impfstoff bis zum 19
februar 1,7 millionen zusätzliche
impfdosen zur verfügung die an die
bundesländer geliefert werden werden die
ersten jetzt heute über heute und morgen
an die bundesländer gehen und dieser
mehr impfstoff wird natürlich verimpft
und jeder jede impfung mehr ist teil
unserer kampagne und was wir jetzt
machen können ist wir haben ja jeder
priorisierung gruppe im grunde menschen
jeden alters auch in der priorisierung
gruppe 1 sind mit den pflegekräften den
ärztinnen und ärzten diejenigen die in
den kliniken in den pflegeeinrichtungen
mit einem hohen risiko arbeiten ja eben
zur sozusagen bevorzugten impfung
empfohlen
und jetzt die ambulanten pflegedienste
im übrigen zum beispiel sind bis jetzt
oder werden jetzt als nächstes in den
fokus der impfkampagne bei den
bundesländern rücken nachdem jetzt vor
allem die stationären
pflegeeinrichtungen die pflegeheime
gehen worden sind das heißt also wir
können in der brio gruppe 1 in denen
besonders verwundbaren bei den besonders
verwundbare und in besonders gefährdeten
jetzt schneller impfen
wir können bei den über 80-jährigen
schneller mehr impfen
weil wir für die unter 64 jährigen in
der gruppe andere impfstoffe zur
verfügung haben und deswegen wird das
die impfkampagne natürlich beschleunigen
dazu vielleicht auch die frage von
christoph lehnert aus dem
ard-hauptstadtstudio wann tritt heuer in
verordnung in kraft und welche gruppen
rücken in der priorisierung dann nach
vorne
sie tritt am montag in kraft wird sie
nachher denkt ich zeichnen und es dann
am montag im bundesanzeiger was es an
veränderungen innerhalb der gruppen gibt
geht vor allem zurück auf überarbeitete
empfehlungen der ständigen
impfkommission die ständige
impfkommission wertet er auch beständig
die daten aus die vorliegen etwa zu der
frage welche vor erkrankungen führen zu
welchen risiken bykow wird 19
und dort hat es eine reihe von
veränderungen gegeben
bei den krankheitsbildern vor allem in
der priorisierung gruppe 2 also der
nächsten gruppe und das wären wir
natürlich abbilden übrigens auch bei
denjenigen die vorerkrankungen haben
gibt es ja sehr viele im alter von 18
bis 64
also auch die werden diese menschen
diesen bürgerinnen und bürgern werden
wir deutlich früher mit diesem impfstoff
ein angebot zum schutz machen können und
deswegen auch weil ihm in sehr hoher
zahlen ja wir hatten mit mehr gerechnet
das haben wir jetzt ja alles die letzten
zwei drei wochen intensiv diskutiert
aber drei millionen mehr impfdosen
allein im februar wie von astra zenica
angekündigt für die lieferung macht
einen echten unterschied im vergleich zu
ohne astra zenica und das wird natürlich
jetzt die impfkampagne insgesamt zwar
weiter beschleunigen ich will aber noch
einmal dazu sagen
um das auch noch mal klar zu haben ist
bleiben trotzdem noch einige harte
wochen der knappheit bei den impfstoffen
vor allem eben
so acht bis zehn wochen jetzt noch bis
ins zweite quartal hinein und deswegen
werden wir weiterhin priorisieren müssen
und deswegen ist die verordnung die am
montag in kraft tritt natürlich auch
wichtig einfach für die handhabung vor
ort entwickeln ich kann von mir aus
nicht sehen
wenn auch sie sich kurz vorstellen
dankeschön
[Musik]
das waren jetzt auch zwei fragen auf
einmal okay kann auch zehn
zusammenhängende fragen schaffen aber
von uns zum ersten auch das weiß ich aus
der biologie von dem biologen geologen
gelernt habe in den letzten wochen ist
das erstmal der umstand dass dieses
virus sich so verändert zeigt dass wir
ihnen auf den fersen sind
das ist also immer schwerer fällt sich
zu verbreiten weil immunität da ist in
teilen in manchen ländern sicherlich
weil es ein anderes ausbruchsgeschehen
gab auch noch mal deutlich mehr als bei
uns in deutschland
das kann mit dem impfen sich eben auch
ergeben und das virus will natürlich
bleiben und verändert sich denn so dass
es im zweifel zum beispiel
ansteckungsfähigkeit wird aber es ist
erst mal auch ein zeichen dafür dass es
sozusagen schwerer wird das virus dass
es beginnt sich zu verändern wenn man
das jetzt überhaupt eigenschaften ist am
ende es ist ja ein tolles ding aber zu
schreiben zu schreiben will und wir
werden jetzt dass das hat der professor
wieder gesagt das haben wir auch
vereinbart mit den laboren mit dem
robert-koch-institut was wir gemacht
haben was die labore gemacht haben noch
mal drei mal mindestens wiederholen in
meinem zwei wochen abstand um zu sehen
wie sich diese knapp sechs prozent jetzt
auch in den nächsten wochen einfach
weiter entwickeln also jenseits der
verstärkten genomsequenzierung ganz
gezielt auf diese drei mutationen hin
auch zusammen mit den laboren sehr
flächendeckend regelhaft sehr viele
positivprobe neben entsprechend
untersuchen weil die frage so zu sagen
hier ist die dynamik oder nicht
den unterschied macht in dänemark sind
glaube ich schon 30 prozent anteil der
mutation und das zeigt eben dass das
dann auch schnell passieren kann und
worum es geht ist gar nicht erst die
chance sozusagen zur dynamischen aus
zu geben das ist ja im moment einmal
mehr das schwierige dieses paradox in
dem wir sind obwohl die zahlen sinken
und auch schon sanken vor 10 14 tagen
wurden die maßnahmen verlängert und
verstärkt erst mal bis zum 14 februar
aber es geht eben darum diesen effekt zu
vermeiden den wert von portugal und
irland gesehen haben denn mit der
portugiesischen kollegin im intensiven
austausch ist sehr dramatisch die
situation in portugal und wenn sie die
zahlen in portugal vor einiger zeit
nehmen und jetzt war viel erreicht und
jetzt ist die lage im völlig anders und
das war in irland auch so und den
umstand wollen wir natürlich vermeiden
ich finde da sind wir uns alle schuldig
nach den harten wochen des verzichts das
jetzt wirklich auch bestmöglich zu
sichern
und am ende geht es ja darum wie wir aus
diesem lockdown ein wenn sie im
englischen bleiben wollen steady state
common der jetzt noch mal neu also neuen
normalzustand der noch mal neu
berücksichtigt auch verstärkt
berücksichtigt diese mutation und das
risiko der mutations verbreitung heißt
also das was wir jetzt schon begonnen
haben medizinische schutzmasken die
besser schützen als die alltags masten
viel regelhafte öfter zu haben wenn
jeder der mit anderen in einem raum ist
und gerade nicht selbst aktiv redet
diese masken trägt dann macht das einen
unterschied vor allem eben auch im
gegenseitigen im gegenseitigen schutz
medizinische schutzmasken noch viel mehr
zu tragen ist aus meiner sicht ein ganz
wichtiger punkt eben in den nächsten
wochen jetzt auch mit blick auf die
mutation die bekannten regeln und
maßnahmen weiter einzuhalten da wo wir
wieder im normalbetrieb
unter pandemie bedingungen gingen in
kitas und schulen mit besonderer
vorsicht das zu machen also all diese
dinge sozusagen zu verstärken auch auf
einem weg in mögliche lockerungen hinein
ob die schon nächste woche beginnen
können oder nicht
darüber werden wir jetzt zahlen des
robert koch institut sind ja gerade erst
veröffentlicht heute morgen darüber
werden jetzt bund und länder miteinander
reden er will er war noch gefragt
also nochmal zu den varianten zum
verständnis warum machen uns die
variante neben sorgen es ist quasi eine
eine neue qualität es gibt ja diese
übertragungs wahrscheinlichkeit also wie
viel steckt eine person an wie viel
andere steckte an und es ist so aus
allen daten die wir jetzt haben die
ersten daten kamen aus dem vereinigten
königreich aber auch aus dänemark und
aus holland sind inzwischen gute
epidemiologische daten da die zeigt uns
dass dieser virus variante wirklich
deutlich mehr andere menschen ansteckt
also der sogenannte erwert der ist um
etwa 0,5 höher
und jeder der sich jetzt mit dem r wert
in den letzten wochen monaten
beschäftigt hat heißt das dass halt
wirklich eine riesige zahl ist und wenn
bei uns die verbreitung anschauen in
diesen ländern in der 46 kalenderwoche
in dänemark zum beispiel war diese
variante bei 0,3 prozent in der zweiten
kalenderwoche dieses jahres bei 73
prozent und in der dritten woche bei 13%
wir haben in portugal ist diese variante
zurzeit bei etwa 60 prozent sie sehen
also wirklich eine starke erhöhung
dieser variante und der grund ist eben
dass diese variante leichter übertragen
wird
das ist der eine aspekt der uns
natürlich sorge macht und der andere
aspekt ist dann wenn die variante mehr
menschen ansteckt egal ob sie jetzt mehr
krank macht oder oder genauso krank
macht wenn einfach mehr menschen
angesteckt werden wird in die anzahl der
menschen die krank sind einfach höher
und damit wird natürlich auch die anzahl
der menschen die ins krankenhaus kommen
hören die in intensivstationen müssen
das heißt also diese varianten sind
wirklich ein die die haben diesen virus
einen boost gegeben und darum müssen wir
wirklich ganz konsequent weiter dafür
sorge tragen dass sie sich nicht so
stark ausbreiten und darum ist es so
wichtig dass auch wenn lockungen
durchgeführt werden zum beispiel in
kitas oder schulen etwas was immer
entschieden wird aber es muss mit
konzepten geöffnet werden dass das ist
wichtig also muss konsequent
schutzkonzepte müssen gefahren
und ich denke das ist eine ganz wichtige
maßnahme wir haben genug gelernt wie wir
das machen können
wir dürfen jetzt nicht nachlässig werden
weil diese varianten sich weiter
ausbreiten matthias gebauer vom spiegel
möchte von wird er wieder wissen die
bewährten der institute die lage in
tirol wo sich die sogenannte südafrika
variante stark ausbreitet und sollte
tirol zu einem sogenannten
virusvarianten gebet deklariert werden
dass er die einreisekontrollen deutlich
verschärfen
nach meinem kenntnisstand hat sich doch
diese variante sehr stark ausgebreitet
ich kann natürlich nicht im detail über
das berichten was in anderen ländern
geschieht aber nach meinem kenntnisstand
und das ist ein kenntnisstand den mir
ein kollege vermittelt hat ist es wohl
dort dazu gekommen dass sehr viele
menschen dort vermeintlich unter der
arbeitserlaubnis skilehrer zu seinen ski
fahren und dort haben sich sehr viele
menschen eben jetzt skiurlaub geleistet
und diese starke anstieg der varianten
ist mit diesem geschehen wird das
ursächlich erklärt und das sagt mir
einfach nur das was ich ihnen eben
gesagt habe das ist eben schlichtweg
keine clevere entscheidung wenn man so
etwas zulässt und darum sollten wir
möglichst modell locken wo wir es
wirklich als unumgänglich sehen das ist
ein geschehen das hätte vermieden werden
können wenn dort nicht so viele tausende
menschen liefen
des gesundheitsministeriums gerne habe
ich auch schon öfter herr grill
beschrieben
zuerst einmal haben wir auf europäischer
ebene öffentlich zugänglich wurde ein
steering committee also die sozusagen
das institutionelle hinter den
verhandlungen wurde ende juni wenn ich
es richtig erinnere im
gesundheitsministerium mit der ende juni
beschlossen auch veröffentlicht ein
steering committee gebildet in dem auch
alle 27 mitgliedstaaten vertreten sind
das eben immer berichtet in dem mit
berichtet wird von der kommission vom
verhandlungsteam wie die jeweiligen
verhandlungen laufen in dem im zweifel
auch grundsätzliche entscheidungen
getroffen werden und dann ist es so
gewesen dass bei den verhandlungen mit
den jeweiligen unternehmen jeweils ist
richtig erinnere zwei mitgliedsstaaten
sozusagen auch mit vertretern dabei
waren geführt hatten die verhandlungen
die kommission
vertragspartner ist die kommission aber
natürlich wie sollte es auch sonst
anders sein deshalb ist ja auch immer
klar gewesen dass rückkopplungen zu den
27 mitgliedstaaten
wir haben ja in die in diesem berühmten
hätte ich beinahe gesagt in antwort auf
den fragenkatalog der ja innerhalb oder
von den ländern vor allem er
federführend gemacht worden ist
aufgezeigt wie häufig wir welches
gremium über welche verhandlungen stände
informiert haben im zweifel müsste ich
sie das ist also sehr lange liste noch
mal auf diese liste verweisen markus
ragg schon reuters möchte wissen wenn
die eu und bayern keck sagen dass 75
millionen dosen der zweiten bestellung
im zweiten quartal geliefert werden
können dann muss doch die erste
bestellung bis dahin komplett geliefert
sein sonst wäre es doch eine täuschung
der impfwilligen wer was der
impfwilligen warum wir das anders ich
kann jetzt kommen die rückfrage
natürlich nicht stellen weil digital
also ich würde jetzt kann jetzt den
begriff täuschung ehrlicherweise haus
der frage und im kontext der frage noch
nicht ganz
wir erschließen die verträge sehen
jeweils sozusagen oder unterschiedlich
jetzt in diesem fall der biontech
vertrag eben bestimmte ab folgenden
lieferungen vor wenn zusätzliche
verträge geschlossen werden
wir sehen die auf bestimmte abfolgen in
der menge vor
vieles davon hängt ja auch zusammen da
sind wir wieder dabei dass wir bereits
im sommer auch begonnen haben mit den
herstellern es vielleicht noch eine
wichtige botschaft mit den herstellern
etwa biontech bezogen auf marburg zu
schauen und immer zu unterstützen wenn
das an uns herangetragen wurde das ist
zusätzliche produktionskapazitäten
braucht und wo es konkrete projekte gibt
marburg ist ganz entscheidend dafür dass
jetzt eben zusätzliche dosen möglich
sind das zusätzliche werk in marburg und
das macht eben nach auskunft von montech
pfizer es möglich diese zusätzlichen
mengen dann auch früher zu liefern ich
finde übrigens sehr ermutigend sie haben
vielleicht vorhin gesehen das ist auch
eine kooperation noch mal verstärkt mit
merkte merk deutsche merck gibt was
lipide angeht das war ja ein ergebnis
aus dem gespräch am montag mit den her
stellen das ist bei lipiden also ein
vorprodukt zu den impfstoffen
engpässe gibt wir haben in dieser woche
allein für weg lexus misst 1
also wir sehen ja jeden tag das sind nur
die dinge die öffentlich werden
natürlich gibt es im zweifel noch viel
viel mehr kooperationen wie viele
kooperationen und zusammenarbeiten
stattfinden und wo immer möglich
gewünscht und manchmal auch ganz
initiative unterstützen wir solche
kooperationen wenn wir irgendwo erfahren
dass die mögliche produktionskapazitäten
sind dann gehen wir auch auf die
unternehmen zu und sagen wäre das was
für euch und das ist genau das was eben
seit wochen stattfindet und was
offenkundig zug um zug auch die früchte
trägt nämlich die dass wir im zweiten
quartal deutlich mehr mengen erwarten
dürfen als im ersten
ich kann es nicht zu der frage der
studien kinder und jugendliche kann
sicherlich auch ihr professor tätig noch
was sagen ich weiß dass einige
hersteller mit entsprechenden studien
begonnen haben
das ist auch ein thema weil ich
gelegentlich die frage kriege warum
kinder noch nicht weil eben wir noch
keine studien haben für kinder und
jugendliche aber wie gesagt der
professor der kann sich ja noch kurz
ergänzen die priorisierung gruppe 1 ich
finde das immer dieses mit den gruppen
ist krieges so technisch aber es ist
also eher jedenfalls geht mit höchster
priorität sind eben die über 80-jährigen
und wie gesagt insbesondere diejenigen
in den kliniken in den
pflegeeinrichtungen in der pflege die
sie begleiten betreuen mit besonderem
risiko mit dem was wir im moment
erwarten dürfen an impfstoffen gehe ich
davon aus jetzt bitte nicht nachher
sagen am 30 märz ist noch nicht 100
prozent aber also um den quartals
wechsel herum dass wir im ersten quartal
ebendort allen ein angebot gemacht haben
werden können
unter der voraussetzung dass die
lieferungen wie geplant für das erste
quartal erfolg und dann kommt mir dann
kommt dann starten wir mit der nächsten
gruppe mit hohem risiko
und dann wird das eben zug um zug mehr
werden können auch an angebot im moment
ist ja noch die herausforderung dass wir
zwar für die quartale schon planzahlen
haben aber noch nicht für die monate
aber wir sind im ständigen gespräch mit
den herstellern und deswegen bin ich ja
weiterhin dankbar für die runde am
letzten montag die denke ich allen
handelnden akteuren auch politisch
verantwortlichen akteuren im land
deutlich gemacht hat was geht an
informationen und sicherheit und planung
und was eben noch nicht geht an
jedenfalls wochenweise planung und
sobald informationen von den herstellern
da sind gehen wir sie auch weiter aber
mit den mengen die wir im zweiten
quartal erwarten dürfen werden wir
sicherlich dann bei denen mit hohem
risiko also den nächsten gruppe auch
sehr sehr vielen ein angebot machen
können
wenn sie genau hinschauen das ist auch
eine große gruppe herzlich zu den kinder
und jugendlichen zum einen möchte noch
mal drauf forschung zu machen dass der
baltikum stoff her zumindest ab 16
jahren zugelassen ist es gibt andere
hersteller die jetzt beginnen kinder
studien zu konzipieren moderner nowaks
andere so schnell sind die ergebnisse da
nicht zu erwarten und sie wissen sind ja
notwendige studien war es möglich ist
dass die dosierung angepasst werden muss
auch hier und da vielleicht formulieren
da geht fallen auch unverträglichkeit im
bereich kinder und jugendliche das läuft
aber im fokus muss ich sagen der zeit
von entwicklung ist neben der
entwicklung für kinder und jugendliche
ganz sicher das thema barrieren und wir
adoptieren dir die impfstoffe auf die
varianten das thema transmission das
heißt können wir hier daten finden dafür
dass die jüngsten dass wir uns nicht
weiter übertragen
entschuldigung herr kind laufe des
halbjahres
ich brauche keine studie um zu wissen
dass ich nicht alle fragen abarbeiten
kann bzw beantwortet werden lassen
können
die ich hier noch auf meiner liste habe
wir machen weiter mit
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage rinke
das hat zwei gründe also zum einen ist
es so dass wir möglichst dass dasselbe
untersuchung spanel haben wollen ja so
dass wir die daten wirklich vergleichen
können also wenn wir jetzt alle zwei
wochen bis zur zehnten woche mit
denselben laboren immer einen ähnlichen
anteil von proben nach untersuchen dann
können wir natürlich die daten viel
besser vergleichen weil es einfach die
stichprobe sehr ähnlich ist unabhängig
davon werden inzwischen auch diese
nachtests finanziert das heißt also
bezahlt die diagnostik tests wer bezahlt
das heißt die labore werden die sowieso
einsetzen
also das heißt das wissen wird dort auch
kontinuierlich erweitert das heißt also
wir werden immer mehr informationen
darüber haben aber wir wollen gerne
dieselbe stichproben damit wir wirklich
den anstieg vergleichen können und der
zweite punkt mit der genomsequenz
beziehung das sind ganz wichtiger aspekt
wir müssen davon ausgehen dass es
zukünftig auch weitere varianten gibt
das ist einfach biologisch zu erwarten
aus vielen gründen ein grund ist eben
das nach wie vor ist so viele
infektionen gibt und jedes mal wenn das
virus von einer person auf die andere
überspringen dann tut sich was sie
können sich vielleicht noch erinnern
nach wie vor allem der besten studie
publiziert worden war der erste webasto
ausbruch der von den münchner kollegen
zusammen mit der gruppe von boston und
nachher auch eine zweite publikation wo
auch wir beteiligt waren publiziert
wurde da sah man ja dass man nachweisen
konnte dass ein virus von einer
patientin zum anderen übergesprungen ist
weil er war eine mutation unterschied
das heißt also es passiert immer
irgendwie
etwas ist und die neuen varianten können
wir nur erkennen mit diesem offenen
blick also dass sie eine
genomsequenzierung machen dann sehen wir
alle varianten und dann mag es sein das
ist jetzt der entscheidende punkt warum
es eine so genannte integrierte
molekulares events geben muss dann
können wir ihn in echtzeit mehr oder
weniger erkennen wenn wir das jetzt
kombinieren mit den meldedaten in
unserem meldedaten steht ja nicht nur
wie viele menschen infiziert wurden und
was wo und wie sondern da stehen ja auch
über die krankheitsdauer die krankheits
intensität krankenhaus-aufenthalt das
heißt also wenn wir dann in der lage
sind zu kombinieren das wissen über die
varianten und das wissen über das
outcome von infektionskrankheiten
gewinnen wir eben einen neuen blick und
was dann geschehen wird ist es werden
dann immer wieder neue pcr-test
etabliert die dann wiederum diese neuen
varianten erkennen und das heißt also
ist ein interaktiver prozess der immer
weiter gehen würde und wir brauchen den
offenen blick und das wird ja auch in
vielen ländern getan wir tauschen dann
die daten aus und ja dass das ich glaub
das ist die antwort darauf ja zur frage
wie werden die impfstoffe gegen die
neuen kursierenden varianten kann man
sagen dass das bild noch uneinheitlich
ist aber es hinweise gibt dass man mit
der uk variante ganz gut fertig werden
kann ist dass afrika passiert vielleicht
schlechter manchmal genau erklären
im ersten ansatz was wir tun ist wir
prüfen ob die antikörper titer die menge
antikörper die wir bei genesenen finden
die mit der alten variante a infiziert
waren oder in und schutz aufgebaut waren
auch gegen die neuen varianten gärten
der zweite trick ist wir versuchen sind
ethisch virusvarianten herzustellen mit
bestimmten mutationen und zu testen ob
da diese zieht auch weiter gegeben sind
und da finden wir das wichtigere
mutationen zum beispiel in der rezeptur
bindungs domäne dass wir den inzwischen
begriff seien durchaus von dem serien
von
menschen die mit dem bayern texter
impfstoff geimpft wurden gut abgefangen
werden
diese titel vergleichen muss man
unterscheiden von echten
wirksamkeitsdaten wo wir gucken ob im
feld menschen die geimpft sind dann auch
vor einer kurve die erkrankung geschützt
sind und weist nochmals darauf hinweisen
auch im hinblick auf den vergleich zu
verschiedenen den stoff produkten dass
hier durchaus leicht verschiedene
maßstäbe angelegt werden als offen ob
sie gegen chur wird mit einem symptom
schützen zwei sind und so weiter
nichtsdestotrotz hier sind bisher
ergebnisse veröffentlicht worden
beispielsweise verlor wachs die gezeigt
haben dass in südafrika mit der
ursprünglichen variante zu 90 prozent
fertig werden den bezirklichen
wirksamkeitsdaten und diese wirksamkeit
bei der südafrika trainieren zum
beispiel zu als zu 60 prozent reduziert
wird
aber insgesamt bin ich ja noch mal
darauf aufmerksam machen dass wir neben
antikörper meldungen natürlich auch
gucken dass die impfstoffe sowohl diesen
teil den antikörper zeigen die zahlen
nun antwort als auch den anti
immunzellen aktivieren anteil der
immunantwort ansprechen insofern ist es
wichtig dass sie jetzt mit den
vorhandenen impfstoffen auch zügig
weiter impfen denn das hilft vielleicht
partiell aber auf jeden fall auch gegen
neue varianten und ich kann sagen dass
jetzt schon mit unserem gespräch sind
impfstoffhersteller auch auf
europäischer ebene wegen uns gedanken
machen wie man einfach adaptieren kann
und da gibt es ja mehrere modelle über
die uhr lange sprechen können
das heißt so adaptieren dass wir den
immunschutz breiter machen können so
dass er sowohl gegen die jetzt
vorhandenen varianten wirkt aber auch
die neuen varianten liefern könnte
wir haben noch von zehn minuten und
vielleicht schaffen wir ja noch fünf
fragen in dieser zeit frau kollegin
bitte
wenn sie in das mikrofon rein sprechen
bitte und wenn sie sich kurz vorstellen
bzw
also zuerst einmal sind das ja fragen
die sich auch an die
verhandlungsführenden kommission richten
unabhängig davon
ich weiß es nicht mehr zu welchem
zeitpunkt kam im nowaks auch in den
blick wir haben ja auch die sind
öffentlich grundzüge vereinbart
sozusagen nach denen die hersteller
ausgewählt werden ich habe ja häufiger
schon gesagt dass nicht nur mit einer
zwei herstellern auch viele pferde
setzen auf verschiedene technologien
deswegen ist übrigens gut dass mit einem
weiteren hersteller bei newel glaube ich
recht im namen der richtigen kopf habe
mit dem tod impfstoff auch dort noch mal
eine weitere sozusagen im technologie
mit in den blick genommen worden ist und
dann ist eben zu einem zeitpunkt
entschieden worden unabhängig jetzt
wirklich davon wo die jetzt
entwicklerteam her ist oder sitzt oder
der produzent mit nowaks verhandlungen
aufzunehmen
die kommission hat uns mitgeteilt dass
sie mit nova wachse den finalen
verhandlungen ist und ich gehe deswegen
davon aus dass wir jetzt auch sehr zügig
diesen vertrag sehen an dem sich
deutschland wie an allen anderen
verträgen auch beteiligen wird
ich kriege ja gelegentlich mittlerweile
die frage auch vom manchem natürlich der
schaut auf finanzielle fragen warum wir
eigentlich noch impfstoff bestellen und
verträge schließen weil wir ja erst mal
von den reinen zahlen her sagen könnten
es reicht aber wir wollen eben
tatsächlich auf nummer sicher gehen ist
mit allen aussichtsreichen entwicklern
verträge haben weil eben etwa mit blick
auf mutationen auf veränderung auch
unterschiedliche wirksamkeit unsicher
dann ergeben können was mir auch sehr
wichtig ist auch das will ich noch mal
wirklich sagen dass wir auch für 2022
vorsorge treffen und kapazitäten für
deutschland sichern keiner von uns weiß
ob es eine auffrischimpfung braucht eine
dritte vanoc nach 12 24 70 monaten weiß
ist noch nicht bewiesen aber ich finde
wir sollten uns vorbereiten und eben für
die frage von mutation auch dort schon
produktionskapazitäten zu sichern
und deswegen werden wir obwohl wir
sozusagen für den erst schritt die
erstimpfung und zwei impfungen für das
erste mal immunisieren mehr als genug
dosen für deutschland gesichert haben
und für die europäische union weitere
verträge auch darüber hinaus schließen
zuerst einmal finde ich es sehr gut dass
ursula von der leyen auch in den letzten
wochen auch sehr aktiv ja mit den
herstellern und im gespräch mit den
herstellern über die probleme die sich
etwa ergeben habe bei lieferzusagen bei
den fragen wer wird wie beliefert auch
dann wenn es zu produktionsengpässen
kommt eingebracht hat und damit hilft
einfach dass die situation besser wird
für uns alle gemeinsam in der
europäischen union auch das darüber
hinaus blicken wie in dem treffen am
letzten sonntag mit den herstellern also
wie viel schaffen wir
wenn jetzt die abkürzung nutzen darf so
etwas wie die amerikanische pendant also
eine institution die auch schnell
daneben entsprechende entscheidungen
treffen kann und finanziell ausgestattet
ist auch auf europäischer ebene ist also
schon der blick sozusagen lesson learned
darüber hinaus dass dort die initiativen
der kommission sind das kann ich nur
begrüßen
und dass insgesamt die impfkampagne
schwierig war das sage ich ja nur schon
auch seit einiger zeit das können wir ja
alle
und das hat dann auch adressaten auf
allen ebenen also ich kann halt damit
nichts anfangen wissen sie habe ich doch
letztes mal schon gesagt das jetzt
irgendwie wir uns alle gegenseitig land
reiter der landesregierung die
landesregierung der bundesregierung die
bundesregierung der kommission und alle
zusammen den herstellern wir uns
erklären was alles hätte besser laufen
können
am ende ist das virus der gegner und wir
schauen mit einander ja was wir besser
machen können vor allem die wir jetzt
schneller an dosen kommen
aber wir müssen auch darüber reden siehe
bader
was wir lernen können für die zukunft
aber wir haben alle gemeinsam und dann
nehme ich jetzt weder die eine noch die
andere ebene aus eben eine verantwortung
und ich finde es gut das ist ja das
ergebnis vom letzten montag dass dieses
gemeinsame verständnis auch zwischen
bund und ländern
da ist das virus ist der gegner und wenn
wir vertrauen behalten wollen dann ist
ganz ganz wichtig aus meiner sicht dass
wir das eben auch gemeinsam immer wieder
deutlich machen
zuerst einmal wissen sie wenn sie so
fragen oder debattieren dann ist das das
ende jeder debatte die menschen sterben
an diesem virus und an den folgen dieses
virus und an dieser krankheit ist eine
pandemie über uns gekommen ein
jahrhundert ereignis und das kostet
leben und verursacht viel leid und dass
wir in dieser schwierigen situation sind
er hat eben mit uns allen im zweifel ja
auch zu tun weil wir jeden tag alle
ringen um die richtige balance zwischen
bestmöglichen infektionsschutz dem virus
so schwer wie möglich zu machen
es bewegt sich allein wenn ich es bewegt
sich nur durch uns und gleichzeitig so
viel es eben geht leben möglich zu
machen und diese balance hat jeder jeden
tag für sich in seinem alltag und diese
haben wir als gesellschaft immer wieder
auszutarieren und das ist schwierig für
jeden von uns im alltag schwierig und es
ist für uns als gesellschaft schwierig
aber wir können jetzt eine debatte also
wie kann jede entscheidung der letzten
zwölf monate nach diesem maßstab
diskutieren nicht nur kann auch jeder
einzelne für sich im übrigen die frage
dann stellen natürlich bei den eigenen
verhaltensweisen dass das dass das am
ende einfach klar sein muss sonst
bleiben wir doch nicht gut beieinander
zusammen dass das virus der gegner ist
und das virus ihr das leid verursacht
und die pandemie ich hätte gerne mit
blick auf die uhr nur übrigens einen
hinweis geben darf selbst ein land wie
israel und das vereinigte königreich
dies zumindest bei den ersten deutlich
mehr haben
wir sind voll locker und ben gurion war
trotz viel mehr impfungen geschlossen
aber ich weiß sogar noch geschlossen ist
der flughafen das zeigt eben dass das
impfen einen unterschied macht für den
der geimpft ist
bei sehr lange dauert es ist insgesamt
in der gruppe nirgendwo steht ein
unterschied macht und trotzdem eben
trotzdem begonnen der impfkampagne wir
alle noch im harten wochen sind das
finde ich es ist einfach wichtig zu
sehen wir mit dem weg raus begonnen aber
es sind auch noch harte wochen die vor
uns liegen in dieser schnell fragerunde
in der bundespressekonferenz noch herr
jung und herr schuster bitte also
zunächst einmal möchte ich noch einmal
etwas prinzipielles sagen es gibt in
dieser gesellschaft immer noch personen
die korona leugnen
es gibt immer noch menschen in unserem
land die bewusst sich gegen masken
entscheiden es gibt immer noch menschen
die das problem nicht ernst nehmen das
möchte ich auch einmal gesagt haben und
es ist sehr wichtig dass alle diese
verstehen dass das virus in unserem land
und in der ganzen welt wirklich eine
eine schreckliche spur hinterlassen hat
und wir können uns davor schützen das
ist das eine das zweite ich weiß nicht
wer diese kotoko wird alles genau
unterstützt
aber das narrativ dass wir die zahlen
runter bringen müssen ist genau das
richtige motiv habe erklärt nochmals es
gibt hunderte gründe warum wir geringe
inzidenz zahlen haben müssen und die
schneller wir die erreichen desto besser
ist es
und darum müssen wir die
infektionszahlen so stark runter kriegen
wie es geht und um das zu tun müssen wir
bestimmte maßnahmen durchhalten und ob
die dann bis zu incident von 10 von
100.000 geht oder bis zu incident von 0
von 100.000 das ist doch dann auch
sicher ein prozess der dann gemeinsam
entschieden werden muss und der dann
auch endlich entschieden werden
aber nochmal meine position ist ganz
klar wir müssen alles tun um die zahl
unterzukriegen so gut wie möglich und
wenn sie auf null geht dann sind alle
menschen die wissen dass dieses virus
uns schaden zufügt glücklich was er will
hat ja vorhin gesagt das virus ist noch
nicht müde und ich ergänze und wir
dürfen es auch nicht werden und um
insgesamt als gesellschaft nicht müde
und müde zu werden ist eben wichtig auch
ziele zu haben miteinander die natürlich
den gesundheitsschutz und das sag ich
als bundesminister für gesundheit ganz
ausdrücklich sehr sehr stark gewichten
stärker als andere facetten die aber
schon in den blick nehmen immer auch was
in anderen bereichen passiert mit
menschen passiert soziale härten
emotionale herten übrigens auch
gesundheitliche folgen wirtschaftliche
folgen die immer auch soziale folgen
haben
also ich kann mir diesen gegensatz
wirtschaft gesundheit weniger anfangen
weil jede wirtschaftliche frage am ende
auch eine gesundheitliche ist und mich
selten auch umgekehrt und das ist ja die
frage um welchen preis
was bei einem land das keine insel ist
in der mitte eines kontinents mit neuen
landgrenzen alleine das übrigens auch
anders besiedelt ist kein outback
sondern sehr dicht besiedelt ist in der
mitte europas
inwieweit was wie unter welchem preis zu
übertragen ist einfach eins zu eins und
ich bin absolut und es ist ja die
strategie der bundesregierung ein
professor wiler wir wollen die instanzen
die infektionszahlen soweit unterbringen
wie es geht
und sie müssen auch weiter runter als
sie heute sind und auch deutlich unter
aber wir haben eben das eigentliche ziel
die überlastung des gesundheits- oder
die belastung ich will auch gar nicht
warten bis es überlastet ist also das
sind kann ich mit dem argument wir
sollen nur auf intensivstationen schauen
auch wenig anfangen möchte nicht erst
immer dass sie voll sind es auch jedes
mal leid für patientinnen und patienten
aber unser hauptziel ist vor allem eben
eine zu starke belastung des
gesundheitswesens zu vermeiden das ist
das ziel seit beginn dieser pandemie
nicht nur bei der bundesregierung
sondern aller politisch oder fast aller
politisch handeln da ich will nicht für
alle sprechen können aber doch
derjenigen die hier auch zusammenkommen
etwa in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
der großen mehrheit des deutschen
bundestages gesundheitswesen nicht zu
stark belasten das ist ein anderes ziel
als 0 infektion sind zwei verschiedene
ziele
das sind liebsten legitimes ziel dessen
legitimes konzept aber muss sich darüber
im klaren sein das ist ein anderes ist
und deswegen ist die debatte darüber ja
auch notwendig aus meiner sicht ist der
preis für eine absolute null zero
strategie unter den bedingungen unseres
landes unter den bedingungen in dem wir
als gesellschaft im moment sind zu hoch
und trotzdem um das gleich hinterher zu
sagen müssen die zahlen deutlich weiter
runter bereits fest
[Musik]
zuerst einmal wir nehmen auch ich
persönlich diese frage natürlich sehr
sehr ernst das ist alles macht doch mit
jedem von uns was haupt also ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass irgendjemand
im raum ist mit dem diese situation in
der wir sind auch in dem jeder einzelne
von uns jeden tag ist das fängt ja schon
bei den masken tragen an
es ist notwendig aber nervig macht das
was emotional physisch psychisch und
menschen können unterschiedlich gut
umgehen jeweils in den situationen mit
solchen belastung und natürlich
entstehen daraus auch die notwendigkeit
zu reden sich auszutauschen
möglicherweise können daraus auch
krankheitsbilder entstehen bei einzelnen
das ist ja im einzelfall berichtet
worauf das ministerium nur hinweis und
hingewiesen hat ist hier die frage so zu
sagen welche welches tatsächlich evidenz
material welche erkenntnisse wir aus
studien tatsächlich darüber haben ob und
was sich verändert hat
im übrigen kann es auch andersrum sein
auch das wird berichtet dass in
bestimmten lebenslagen dadurch dass das
leben weniger stressig geworden ist in
manchen berufen
auch wieder also zum beispiel bei
herzinfarkten sehen wir auch andere
zahlen als ohne krone an vielen stellen
niedriger
die frage ist ja woher kommt das ist das
weil sie weniger stattfinden oder weil
sie weniger entdeckt werden und wenn sie
weniger stattfinden finden sie
eigentlich weniger stark weil
möglicherweise weniger stress also es
ist jetzt alles wie sie merken er
beschrieben aus der eigenen empirie als
eben tatsächlich aus belastbare evidenz
und das ist das worauf wir hinweisen
dass wir diese belastbare evidenz aus
sozusagen behandlungsdaten eben im
moment noch nicht haben
die wird sicherlich auch geben und geben
können und das gilt für andere bereiche
auch und wir unterstützen auch in
studien auch in anderen bereichen
viele die krankenkassen machen das im
übrigen auch mit ihren
wissenschaftlichen instituten die
natürlich genau das untersuchen wir
müssen alles in den blick nehmen die
gesundheitlichen folgen durch corona und
diejenigen wegen kohle entschuldigung
nein wir machen jetzt sehr sind nie wir
sind in der in der schnell fragerunde
und wir sind schon über die zeit und ich
muss jetzt wirklich wegen des nachfolge
termins der regierungs-pressekonferenz
diese pressekonferenz an dieser stelle
beenden sagte herzlichen dank muss bei
allen um verständnis bitten deren fragen
offen geblieben sind
das nächste mal dankeschön dankeschön